what's going on in this man's world
getting set to call his v the United
States Open Golf Championship for Fox
and tonight his st. Louis Blues play
game 7 in Boston against the Boston
Bruins he's none of than Joe Buck how
are you Joseph I'm great I hope you guys
are well now we're doing good
where are you watching Game seven
tonight you'll say you have it all set
up can you watch it with other people do
you watch it by yourself how are you
with this joke I don't want to watch it
with anybody I tried that I mean I let
them at this in my seats at home right
and I have no choice but it would be
weird actually if I cleared everybody
out and just had them play for me and my
whoever I bring to the game that I
deployed as being in Pebble Beach I'm
near Brad Faxon is a big Bruins fan and
I've watched two games with him and both
games the Blues got kind of blown out so
I not only am I not gonna watch with
Brad I don't even want to see Brad today
I've told him that Fox is okay with that
we are being separated and I'm gonna
watch in my room screaming at the
television no so okay that's that's what
what would it mean Joe if the Blues win
tonight you're the perfect person to put
this into words what would it mean for
the city for the fans who have been
rooting for them for so long if the
Blues were able to hoist the cup tonight
man it's hard for me to speak for an
entire city I know that personally I was
introduced to the Blues by my dad and
being a fan and what it meant he was
their first voice on the radio and they
always had a really secure spot in his
heart and I saw how he watched and was
jumping on the couch when they would you
know come close to scoring a goal or be
ticked off when they gave up a goal and
so I fell in love with it at a young age
and I would watch a lot of games with my
dad and that as the years went on and I
became a dad but the daughters were
right alongside me and it was the one
thing that I'm able to go to as a fan
and share that experience with my
daughters and and be openly crazy about
the
and high-five strangers in the seats I
think the city's been through a lot
I think downtown st. Louis needs to get
its act together and take a couple steps
forward but the people there are great I
think they get a bad rep for the Rams
having left despite I think tremendous
support when they were you know at the
very least competitive and you know I
think there been a lot of long-suffering
blues fans to kind of feel like cubs
before 2016 or the Red Sox fans new
generations before 2004 and a lot of
that for us and I think would go away I
think the trip to this point has been
worth every bit of it anyway but it
would be cool to see them win the Cup
and and I think it gives the city a real
lift you do realize Joe that well you do
realize I know this that you're you're
accused all the time and unrightfully so
of rooting against other peoples teams
tonight though Boston Boston Bruins fans
tonight could actually accurately accuse
you of rooting against their team
tonight no let's make no mistake about
it I am rooting against loss and I
wasn't for San Luis and but when it
comes to the baseball stuff or the
football stuff right really what it what
it boils down to is I'm not there
rooting for them and that they hear and
announcers all year especially in
baseball rooting along with them and I
get it because when I'm I mean I'm not
only a I'm a season ticket holder but
I'm the majority of the games I watch
are on TV and so John Kelly and Darren
pang are the guys that are calling the
action and they have the same rooting
interest that I do and then when the
games matter the most they're gone and
you have somebody that's splitting it
down the middle and getting excited for
the Bruins when they score and that's
their job and the same for the Blues but
you want to hear people on TV that have
the same Allegiance and allegiances that
you do and when you don't it's unnerving
when you haven't hurt that's all year so
I understand all that stuff but this is
one that I'm not related to work wise
and so I make no bones about it I mean
I'm a blues fan and have been since I
was a little kid and him
do you know is hey I'm gonna be there do
you know if jon Hamm's gonna be rich I
don't know I haven't been texting with
them I I just keep up with them in all
the NBC promos it's like it goes like
Perico and Pietrangelo and Chara and
Krug and Doc Emmerich and Jon Hamm
you know what he's just a handsome guy
but you understand that right it's just
he's a guy well I do so and I think
we're all jealous of the granite lake
that he has and and the whole thing
Scott well it's cold in these hockey
arenas before the fans you know they're
not used to be but I think that they've
kind of perfected that were the actual
experience for fans is not one where
you're freezing so I don't know I don't
know what the scarf thing is but I'm
gonna get to the bottom of it within the
next month Joe Buck
Fox Sports here on the Rich Eisen show
unapologetic to root against your team
to not if you're a Boston Bruins fans
here go ahead and hate me for being a
blues fan that's fine that's what it's
all about
that's the fun part of being a fan so
and then being a fan - I know obviously
you're a lead-pipe wielding professional
got a US Open it's got it's got to be
pretty cool walking around Pebble Beach
saying I'm gonna call an event here and
it's the US Open that's got to be pretty
cool this week for you Joe it's like go
I've said to somebody the other day it's
like getting ready to do a World Series
at old Yankee Stadium or Fenway or
Wrigley or it's like calling an NFC
Championship game at Lambeau it's just
it's just different you know it feels
big and people here the security is
unbelievable I mean it is impossible to
get around here it is lockdown and if
you're going to be locked down in some
place being locked down looking at the
Pacific Ocean and a golf course and the
landscape around here it's pretty
spectacular and and I think the
storylines on the PGA Tour and what's
happened in the majors already this year
with Tiger and then Brooks koepka we
know sets up for you Rory fire
in here after what he did in the
Canadian Open I think there's a there's
a potential here for a really cool
leaderboard and that's not even
mentioning Phil yeah and and obviously
kepco going for three in a row I mean he
owns back-to-back PGA's he owns
back-to-back US Opens nobody's ever been
able to say that at one single moment in
history and I we played it just in
earlier in the show your video with
Kefka this week where he told you do
such a great job with Romo and called
you Jim that was that was fantastic Joe
that was very very good next level next
level stuff self-deprecation I sat down
with them and did an interview and he
was great and I know he mentioned Fox in
his press conference saying that Fox
didn't have in the promo we have isn't
really accurate and the side of the Fox
building in LA I believe has a gigantic
picture of Brooks kept good but all that
being said I think that's just kind of
the way he operates these days he wants
motivation he wants to hear the crowd
chanting BJ DJ when a lead is slipping
away on the back nine of the pga or he
wants you know to feel like everybody at
Belle Reve and st. Louis wanted Tiger to
win and that motivates him and so he
tries to find little things that get
under his skin
some are legit and I think some are kind
of manufactured but that's the way he
gets fired up and whatever he's doing he
should keep doing because he's the
number one player in the world well I
mean it seems like he's equal
opportunity when it comes to that so
much was made of his his girlfriend
coming up to him before the round at the
PGA and he was just laser focused on
everything what is he like Joe I mean is
he like the guy rate dropped into your
video like that yeah he was he was all
smiles he was happy he I think the
interview is really good we talked about
the girlfriend thing and it's gonna run
today we have a fs1 show kind of a
preview show and you know we joked
around about it and he's funny and he's
a real sports fan you know his great
uncle's dick
groats who won two World Series and also
played in the NBA
he's got great athletic genes in his
family I think you know he could play
pretty much any sport he'd rather be
playing baseball but he's the world's
number one golfer it he's a huge
baseball fan he's a Red Sox fan
he's an Astros fan because his
friendship with Jim crane and he's just
a regular kind of guy's guy so there's
nothing not to like off-camera or
personally unless you're trying to beat
him here at Pebble Beach
then there's plenty to not like because
he's really freaking good and isn't
scared of anybody out there Joe Buck
here few more minutes left with Joe on
the Rich Eisen show whether gonna be
good
everything looks good again the videos
that you've been sending out it looks
perfect so I'm wondering if it's gonna
look amazing it is perfect and they've
had a ton of rain I think the most rain
they've ever had in May so it's lush you
know you think of US Open especially
recently and it's the glass your
Shinnecock its kind of browned out it's
thinned out you know they make it as
difficult as they can but these fairways
are holding if somebody's accurate off
the tee and here with a couple of
exceptions you really don't have to be
that long off the tee everybody's in
this and so to speak because it's not a
bombers paradise so some guys you know
are going to maybe hit three four
drivers the whole round and if that's
the case and that brings a lot of
players into the potential winter circle
and I've talked to guys that know a lot
more than me but they're thinking 10 12
under unless the wind blows and right
now that was supposed to get windy maybe
Friday Saturday supposed to be ideal on
Sunday so weather-wise it couldn't be
any better I'm fired up about it
that's awesome did you have you ring it
did you ring on Jim Nance's door and run
up there in the Monterey Peninsula Jove
you've done that yeah I did I did yeah
how'd that work well actually no I
sneaked around the back and I played the
7th hole is replica 7th hole here at
Pebble Beach in his backyard and turned
on the
music and I spend a couple hours back
there
you know what Joe just that's that's
just you being you I would expect no
less
that's fantastic I would and he he did
that same kind of thing when the PGA
Championship was in st. Louis I woke up
one morning and he was just swimming in
my pool that's odd
that's odd but that but you know what I
would expect no less a gym that's just
you and no no that's just you and Jim
doing your thing all right good luck
we've always had bad we've always well
good luck to your blues tonight Joe I'll
be thinking of you watching that game
tonight I will be here at Pebble Beach
watching alone in my room with a scarf
around my neck yeah by the way ham just
texted me he's wondering why he wasn't
in the Fox promo that one of the four
that kepco was not in how come ham
wasn't in the one no link he's in a
couple of okay very good
take care Joe have a great Father's Day
best to Michelle all right thank you
guys you together that's Joe Buck at
buck on Twitter and tonight Bruins fans
can absolutely tweet at him saying
you're rooting against my team because
it's fact
four more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app